et jacques almas quand jean-marie de
liga
je vous demande de nous
aïe bon il faudra jamais eu autant de
bruit que les 13000 personnes de bercy
mais enfin bon si c'était pas loin gars
c'était pas loin mais un bravo pour eux
jean-marie bonsoir bonsoir
donc avant de commencer avant de parler
de justement du spectacle de bercy enfin
bigard remet le paquet vous faire une
confidence parce que quand j'allais voir
votre sketch
je peux maintenant pratiquement disant
s'appeler les grandes causes
j'étais heureux parce que d'un seul coup
je voyais quelqu'un qui sur scène
raconter quelque chose que moi je
ressentais c'est à dire toutes ses stars
au service des causes et finalement je
me suis dit à ce moment là c'est vrai
que c'est sans doute plus les les les
causes qui aide les stars que les stars
qui aide les causes voilà ce que je
pensais à l'époque en voyant ce sketch
et puis finalement j'ai évolué et je me
suis rendu compte que si on peut nous
gens de télévision ou de ou de
spectacles mettre notre notoriété au
service des autres là est bien il faut
le faire voilà et je pense que vous avez
cette évolution là aussi et puis le fait
d'être une star comme tu dis ou d'être
quelqu'un de connu c'est vrai que tu as
un filet qui est beaucoup plus gros tu
ramasses beaucoup plus de gens et puis
est ce que tu penses est plus important
et donc si tu penses bien si tu vois le
bien si tu fais le bien c'est toujours
toute façon mieux quoi ça encourage tout
le monde à le faire et plus que ton
charcutier même si c'est un mec je ne
sois pas voilà quoi alors dans les
grandes courses que vous avez défendu il
ya eu les restos du coeur que vous avez
vraiment animée oui avec énormément de
plaisir
tout ça sous la houlette de jean jacques
goldman qui est un fédérateur justement
formidable c'est à dire qu'elle sait
sûrement le seul mec en claquant des
doigts qui fait venir
soixante quinze chanteurs qui aimerait
tous d'accord pour chanter la danse des
critères s'il le faut à quatre pattes et
donc ça c'est vachement bien et tout le
mérite lui revient
jean jacques goldman et puis à les
bouchons et moi les bouchons et wario
land et cherchant à mars à mort les
bouchons des bouchons c'est incroyable
j'en ai les larmes aux yeux je bien joué
le groupe l'un viager et serge et il
allait y est tu sais c'est une solution
pour que le monde entier a eu l'idée on
regarde les petits bouchons ce que les
bouchons de boissons et s'éteint c'est
un plastique est assez noble et qu'on
peut recycler tant de fois qu'on veut ça
dure trois mille emplois
une action écologistes on demande pas de
pognon et ça permet à chacun de faire
une action d'amour y compris à ceux
qu'ont beaucoup de pognon parce que même
les riches peuvent garder vos champs il
obtient on se maquille up et garde le
bouchon quand même il ya boys et puis ça
a pris j'ai plus de 300 bigard chant qui
sont quand même des deschamps que je
remercie énormément parce que ces gens
qui stocke 10 tonnes de bouchons
chez eux et après il ya un camion qui
vient on ramasse 200 tonnes de bouchons
par mois donc il ya des fois des gens
qui me disent c'est terminé les bouches
en ont c'est jamais terminé
on peut le faire tout le temps zéro
franc 0 euro de frais de fonctionnement
c'est très important ils vont où ces
bouchons après ces bouchons recyclés
tout simplement ils seront concassés et
puis après ils sont remis un petit
billet qui sont prêtes à injecter pour
faire n'importe quoi ils soient des
pare-chocs de bagnoles des palettes
maintenant qu'on fait en plastique et
tout ça d'ailleurs si ça intéresse les
gens cette matière première parce que on
en ramasse tellement que la société qui
nous les reprend elle elle commence
presque à saturer donc c'est du
plastique qui coûte donc 500 francs la
tonne il a racheté 500 formateurs parce
qu'on à 350 francs de transport est donc
assez génère du pognon 200 tonnes de vos
chances avait cent mille balles par mois
et avec sa machette des fauteuils et ont
fait un orphelinat à madagascar 6 sur
cinq cents francs il ya 350 francs de
transport le transport pour être moins
cher si la sncf s'en occupe et ouais
c'est ça c'est super génial j'ai
rencontré le ministre des transports qui
m'a choqué sur wii qu'essayer de qui m'a
dit je vais essayer de faire quelque
chose et puis à plein de gens qui
essaient de nous aider évidemment si les
gardes venait dé des dépôts n'arrêteront
de 5000 dépôt en france
et si le chimiste était d'accord pour
qu'on prenne les bouchons des
cosmétiques publierait par 6 le tonnage
et ça peut faire ça c'est déjà en
belgique ça se fait en suisse
il désespère pas de le faire
dans toute l'europe et pourquoi pas dans
le monde entier pourquoi jeter un truc
qu'on peut réutiliser et faire aux
réunions lille ce refus et effet à
essayer de faire du bien quoi bon
alors
vous savez jean marie qu'on reçoit
beaucoup de mails dans cette émission
dont un de nathalie thomas de nantes qui
me dit je sais que vous allez recevoir
jean marie bigard le 23 février
j'ai vu onze fois le spectacle bigard
remet le paquet et à chaque fois c'était
génial
c'est énorme elle vit par votre
intermédiaire j'aimerais le remercier
beaucoup pour sa gentillesse je
n'embrasse bien fort en espérant que sa
main va mieux merci nathalie mais qu'est
ce qu'il y avait à la main mieux ma main
va mieux mais j'ai encore une petite
baisse mais après qu'est ce qu'il y
avait à la main je me suis cassé la
gueule 48 heures avant un bercy alors
elle dit j'espère bientôt le revoir sur
scène mais bon là maintenant quand même
les sens si je mens je vais m'y remettre
je suis en train de réécrire un nouveau
spectacle là et que je vais fortement
attaquées en automne ah ouais et dont
j'ai le thème et il ya mon lolo ma fille
qui est notre ami commun qui veut sans
être dans les écritures avec moi parce
que je vais faire un spectacle sur
l'idée que l'animal est que l'homme et
l'animal le plus évolué de la planète il
ne devrait s'en féliciter chaque matin
ouais c'est comment on fait jean maria
et
chez le chien maintenant c'est fait de
la pub c'est le chien de pavlov la pub
là alors c'est abel bigard bon bercy
donc à une cassette un dvd
et puis alors il ya évidemment une
demi-heure de séquences inédites et
insolites en plus sur les coulisses de
bercy
oriali coulisses et puis il ya et puis
le dvd ces deux heures de bonus toute la
tournée un an de tournée c'est vraiment
un collector puisque c'est un an de
tournée phénoménal avec moi on va voir à
quoi ça ressemble à l'est